hey what's up guys I'm Duff Goldman I
own some bakeries and I'm on some shows
on Food Network so today we are going to
make a mirror glaze for an entre made on
Treme is a cake it's layered it's
usually mousse but you can use
buttercream and know that when you first
see something like a miracle you really
freak down kind of intimidating because
it does look a little bit scary but I
promise it's like four ingredients and
it's super super easy
gelatin won't really do anything in a
powdered form you add water to it then
it becomes a usable workable product
poured the hot stuff over the chocolate
and the gelatin and the milk because the
chocolate in the gelatin and the milk
are a little bit more sensitive and so I
don't want to cook that stuff there's
nothing you can do to chocolate to make
it any better so you'd be really gentle
with them I've been baking for a long
time you know over 20 years and it's
pretty rare that I make something like
completely new so this is kind of
exciting for me you know and how
everybody come over the book oh my god
that cake is so amazing they're gonna
think that you got it from like a
professional pastry shopping you just
made it you want this to be about 90
degrees you can kind of tell you just
sort of touch it it really looks like
you know paint all right now for the fun
part when you get the edges first
because we want to make sure the edges
get covered because the center is going
to happen regardless
here's the second color
I recommend do this until you're like
not having fun anymore take a spoon and
get finer lines to see how the glades
are sort of like dissolves into itself
now it looks great now but glitter makes
everything better it looks amazing
look at that alright that's it that's
how you make a mirror cake the nice
thing about a glaze like this is that
you saw it was like super organic it
flowed out and it looks like a really
really fancy cake and it was super easy
to do oh yes
[Music]